I know how to kill Deadpool but it won't
be easy I mean he literally has
Wolverine's healing Factor who has
recovered from a single drop of blood
before the healing Factor makes him
basically immune to disease even cancer
can't kill this guy plus when his cells
die they immediately regenerate which
means that Deadpool is not going to be
getting any older so then how do you
kill him well believe it or not it's
actually pretty easy because the healing
Factor has one huge weakness the brain
memory you see memories aren't a
physical thing inside of your brain
they're actually electrical signals that
balance between different neurons in
your brain in a very specific pattern
and sure Deadpool's healing Factor can
regenerate those neurons but it can't
regenerate those specific patterns
they'll forget the electrical signal so
destroy Deadpool's brain and even when
it grows back you won't be able to
remember that he was Wade Wilson in the
first place and believe it or not but
like the worst X-Men movie ever actually
got this one right X-Men Origins
Wolverine showed this exact same
scenario happening to Logan I guess they
had to make up for that horribly
inaccurate Deadpool with some horribly
accurate Neuroscience so there you go